the nfl was planning to play this fall
that's our hope and that's our planning
uh today
we can help our country heal we can help
bring our communities together we can
provide hope we can provide a
distraction from the everyday issues and
show people that
there is a future out there and that
we're all going to be part of that
that's the first we've seen and heard
directly from roger goodell since the
pandemic began last month and it popped
up kind of without much fanfare on the
nfl's instagram account peter and i i
think it's useful at times like this to
hear from people like roger goodell the
guy who runs the most popular sport in
america there are a lot of
impressionable people out there that are
getting mixed messages and to the extent
that you can provide a message of hope a
message of positivity i think it's very
important i'm glad that roger goodell
did it but
every time i hear
the nfl is planning to play
i understand that we want to project
optimism and hope i just think the more
accurate statement is we're planning for
every possible scenario and i hope they
are i hope they aren't simply planning
to play but planning for everything that
can happen because one thing we've
learned over the past month
anything can happen and anything has
happened in the past four weeks
well mike you know we're all trying to
uh
you know divine what exactly is going to
happen going into the future
and so and i think we're all somewhat
anyway we're all these days at least
kind of news junkies
and and so the other night i was
watching the pbs newshour judy woodruff
and she has an interview with bill gates
and bill gates obviously has got a lot
of
experience with his philanthropy in
africa and around the world with
vaccines he's he's
he basically become an expert in this
field
and he he said in so many words that
when judy woodruff asked him about
big gatherings of people and conventions
at conventions or or stadiums
and bill gates said essentially that you
know he does not think it's a very good
idea until
there is a vaccine
and so until
if you take that a step further
i i don't hear anybody saying yep by
november we'll have a vaccine i mean
and again
all i'm doing is trying to spitball just
like we all are and sometimes that's a
little bit dangerous
but my feeling is that it's unrealistic
to think
that you know on september 10th when the
kansas city chiefs if the kansas city
chiefs open the season at arrowhead
stadium it's unrealistic to not even
consider
that there might not be fans in the
stands and i've talked to a few players
this week who've openly talked about the
fact that we're probably going to play
some games without fans in the stands
and so i think the sooner people start
to kind of wrap their head around that i
think the sort of the better and the
more realistic it will be for people
trying to anticipate the future
i agree with you completely and the
problem is when you speak like that
there are people who get riled up and
say you're being an alarmist you're
being unrealistic well we're being
realistic and we don't want to create
false hope there's nothing wrong with
hope
but i think it's detrimental to fill
people's heads up with ideas that don't
come to fruition because then peter it's
just one disappointment after another
anybody who was looking forward to
watching ufc 249 finds out last night
that's not going to happen people
looking forward to seeing baseball in
june they're going to be disappointed if
they find out that's not going to happen
so i think the hope needs to be
realistic and everyone needs to be
pragmatic and and it is a very simple
chain of logic it's going to be
impossible to get back to where we were
without a vaccine for this virus period
and the big concern is we alluded to
last segment wave two wave three the
news last night told me that wave three
of the spanish flu was the worst wave
that we thought we were over it twice
and people let the guard down and it
came back worse the third time so until
there's a vaccine i agree with you the
idea of full stadiums or anyone in
stadiums seems incomprehensible but but
it's still important for the people who
run our private institutions to provide
messages of hope and i was inspired by
the way that roger goodell closed his
comments that emerged earlier this week
listen to what roger goodell had to say
and come to your own conclusion as to
whether or not you find it inspiring i
do
we're going to get through this um we're
going to get through this together we're
going to get this as a country and as a
as a world
and that um
this is something that we're going to
we're going to to overcome
and you know people should keep that
hope because uh
we're going to get back to doing the
things that we were doing and hopefully
creating a great future for so many
people and i hope everyone stays
involved and does what's best in our
communities in the short term but more
importantly keeps focusing on
the future because it's going to be a
great future for us
see it's simple to deliver that message
but it's also very important it's very
powerful because we're living in this
groundhog day existence where every
morning i got you babies playing at 6 00
a.m and we slammed our hand on the clock
and here we go with another day and we
have no idea when this is going to end
and it's important to hear from people
just that simple very basic but very
pure and true message that we are going
to find a way through this that it is
going to get back to normal at some
point however long it takes we're
climbing that mountain peter
one inch at a time and we have no idea
where the top is but when you hear
messages like that from people of high
position high level of trust and yeah
they they boo him at the draft that
sport but roger goodell is still the guy
who is at the very top of the nfl
pyramid that i think is helpful to
people and and those little messages can
help people get through
one day a rough day a bad day you hear
something like that it gets you through
that bad day so i encourage him and
others in positions like that to keep
putting those messages out there to keep
us all moving in the direction that we
all need to be moving
yeah and and mike look i i mean
i i think that everybody should
basically keep their eye on the prize
and the prize being getting back to a
normal life
and if you keep your eye on the prize
about getting back to a normal life then
that means you're not going to be
careless and you're not going to say
well i'm going to jump over this fence
and me and eight buddies are gonna go
play basketball um you know it's
interesting yesterday i was talking to
chris harris jr you know the new
cornerback of the los angeles chargers
last year his workout his workout
routine
in texas where he lives in dallas was
his trainer had about 20 to 25 people
who every day would go they do some
lifting they do some drills uh they'd be
on a a football field in dallas so this
year what they've done chris harris jr
said it sort of looks like a field day
you know around said we have five guys
who don't come close to each other and
the way the routine is they all are on
different stuff
which is obviously cleaned off and and
all that
and so all of this stuff is done
trying to keep in mind we are getting
ready
okay but we're getting ready in a
different way than we ever have before
and that is the thing to keep in mind
okay there are ways to do
some of this stuff that you've always
done but to do it in a more careful way
and to not
just be careless so to me
you can keep your eye on the prize
getting back to a normal life and you
know what some of the new normal is not
going to be what it used to be
i keep thinking to myself
you know
if i could sign right now
for a 12-game season without a buy that
starts on october 18th
and maybe for either part or all the
year there are no fans in the stands
quite honestly i'd sign for that right
now because to me what it means is that
you will play the nfl season in some
degree
of regularity you might not have fans in
the stands
but
what is the strength of the national
football league for its consumers the
televised product and i know everybody's
gonna say oh my god it won't be the same
at arrowhead stadium without the sea of
red well of course it won't
but we're not the same either and you
just have to say to yourself okay
could we have 70 percent of the
enjoyment
you know i mean and and the fans are not
there
i'd rather have 70 percent of the
enjoyment than not have games
and the bottom line is if those games
have to proceed without fans present
that means we're going to still be
subject to some degree of the
restrictions that are keeping us at home
and we're going to need those games
we're going to want those games we're
going to want that thing we can look
forward to at the end of each week to
see our favorite team play to have our
fantasy team in action whatever the case
may be it's something that breaks up
that notion that every day is the same
one day after the other like i said
earlier bill murray slamming his hand on
the clock when sonny and cher are
singing that song at 6 a.m in
punxsutawney pennsylvania we can only
take so much of that we need things to
look forward
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports